yeah so he's a very intellectual
streamer he um is very philosophical and
goes into depth on stuff while playing
video games so I just wanted to get your
thoughts and see what you have to okay
I'm not reacting to his video gaming
skills though because I don't know [ __ ]
about that now you gotta rank his 90s
too his what his 90s yeah
yeah all right let's get going
[Applause]
hey
see I'm looking at this as a mother like
on the other side of that door hearing
that [ __ ] happen and running in there
and going what are you doing in here I'm
sure that that has happened to him a
thousand times with his mother yeah
there's videos with his parents they're
hilarious he's like one of the most
famous streamers in the world right now
oh yeah
okay why this game's so fun chat
oh please [ __ ] I will give you my ass I
swear to God I'll give you my ass I'll
give it let's go
foreign
[Music]
so these are these are all a bunch of
rappers um this is this is Eden Ross
have you seen did we watch the thing
with Tate and Aiden Ross
Tate just Tate just roasts them you know
but um these are all just rappers and
[ __ ] and so they all just get together
and make content and stuff it was just
like invite the token white guy you're
used to a lot more intellectual content
so yeah you just said this guy goes deep
and philosophical and there's a lot you
lied Anthony Davis
[Applause]
real quick man
nobody
oh [ __ ] I'm tweaking bro what
do you remember when when I was little
and we were playing we
um we both we bowling in the house yeah
and when Robert was behind me and I
whipped I whipped the Wii remote behind
right into his nuts yes he was on the
floor for like 20. I wish he was here to
tell that story because you really got
him good yeah this tiny little sunny and
sunny got so into wheat and he really
just threw his arm all the way back and
slammed
our grown cousin guess what
guess what he's on the phone with his
Dad or not guess what
I'm good
burn then do you support black lives
matter
yes
do you support lgbtq
[Laughter]
it is pretty funny I can't lie like you
obviously don't get anything out of
watching this [ __ ] but it's hilarious
could you see how young people could
watch this stuff or are you just like
just like absolutely absolutely I didn't
say I'm not entertained I'm just saying
like No One's Gonna watch want to watch
me watch this because I don't know trust
me this is going to be one of our most
viral videos this dude's like I think
almost more popular than Tate in a
different way it's crazy
seven one I just don't have a lot to to
prepare to provide
wow
that's cool
wow I'm a crap [ __ ]
so that his mom will come in and like
start screaming at him that's right with
the YouTubes yeah but if it's fine if
you're freaking like not if you wrecking
your family's lives but I do hope that
the neighbors are far enough away how
old is this guy like 17. oh good for him
he's killing it right now though
virtual hi
hi
oh
did you see him I saw him I don't get it
though
you got time oh he got tackled okay
no you're playing bro hey little some
real [ __ ] just like a friendly mess bro
whoever win this bit whoever win bro
that's who it is all right
all right come here come on
so that's like he's fighting a dog
that's like an AI dog where you can ask
it questions online damn [ __ ]
he's screaming so loud it's like it's
like an AI dog and it'll give you a yes
no maybe
and or just like hang up on you so you
can just talk to it and say whatever
it's kind of like a magic eight ball
oh we have a Magic 8 Ball yeah do you
know who that is
laughs
hi my name's Steve
no you know what's great how many bus
ticket do you need
oh
no no no yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right below
Haram all right if you're gonna make me
watch a lot of this you're gonna I'm
gonna watch like a Charlotte McClain
movie or something yeah I worry
I'm 16.
let's just try to learn how to do this I
think this might be the forming
statement goodbye
wow
what do you think of this fortnite
skills what do you rate it
this is definitely the dumbest video
we've ever watched
I can't do this for I don't know I don't
know how people do this for hours oh no
this is like a quick tick tock smile and
scroll
but
[Music]
I like to guys for the dogs on Tick Tock
he's my favorite
um one of one of my favorites
that sounds weird
questions Ben where you at
oh speed three turn around
what all right pause for a second
off
for the editors just as a side
conversation like is any this is going
to be a terrible video I'm telling you
this is going to get used
yeah but
contributing anything I have zero
interest in this and you you're we're
barely it's barely generating any kind
of conversation we're just gonna have
people watch us watch this for 10
minutes yeah
you can keep that in by the way okay
fine I know I know we usually watch time
keep it in let's teach everybody your
your tricks what what is the value in
this she's one of the most Googled
people on the internet right now people
want to see people reacting to him even
if you're bored I've got nothing to say
except you
gets really loud inside here when he
scream
scream yeah he does four more minutes of
this [ __ ] I like the dog I like the
dog's attitude like like and how is his
I like how the dog like his arms move
just a little like he's breathing and
he's just trying to control himself
because he wants to rip this kid's face
off what this is this is the meta verse
by the way
this is where we're at this is where
we're at for the metaverse right now
it's pretty cool I want to go there can
we go
can we go first you want to go here well
not necessarily
separate I want to go somewhere nice in
the metaverse for sure for sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what would you do if I was screaming
like this in the house but I was making
millions doing it would you put up with
it or would you come and just whack me
or buy the apartment next door for
videos
um I would say I don't know if I was
used to it already I'd say 25 days out
of the month you would get to live and
the other five days I would come in
there and
lose my mind on you oh my god even when
I was playing fortnite I got too loud
you get so mad
do I ever get loud now when I'm filming
or anything
alone no you're you're you're growing up
now yeah yeah
I think you started screaming like that
now I think something was legit wrong
what would you give speed one to ten or
what are your what are your overall
thoughts on that [ __ ] I'm not eight
years old so I'm not I I I'm all speeded
out I actually would like to have a
conversation with this kid and know what
goes on in his head though because I
like the way his mind
whose brain works in in his Madness but
I don't want to watch any more of those
videos yeah we can watch a intellectual
one next oh all right so would you rate
speed of one out of ten or nothing not
reading him I don't understand I don't
even understand it's like it's a whole
different language that you just showed
me like that's America I don't even know
I don't even know what goes on well
speed Tick Tock accounts you can go
repost in the mom reacts to Speed videos
thank you guys for watching make sure to
join the Discord in my bio this is where
I teach how to make money how to use the
algorithm to your advantage and you can
post stuff for us to react to and
whatnot so it's pretty cool people are
making money we have a bunch of
subscribers already staying subscribed
it's happening
[Music]
[Music]